[Musique]
depuis quelques temps un sujet fait
régulièrement l'objet de débat souvent
houleux la transidentité un droit que
revendique de plus en plus les jeunes
générations en 2021 alors ministre de
l'éducation nationale Jean-Michel
Blanquer mettent en place une circulaire
pour protéger les élèves transgenres à
l'école les élèves de collège ou de
lycée pourront se faire appeler par un
autre prénom que celui choisi par leur
parent tout enfant quel que soit son
orientation sexuelle doit se sentir bien
à l'école vouloir changer de genre un
désir souhaité par certains enfants
comme Lily qui avait ému une partie de
la France j'ai su que j'étais une fille
vers la maternelle mais aujourd'hui des
boîtes tentent de se faire entendre à ce
sujet de l'association SOS Éducation
parfois critiquée pour ses prises de
position à même lancer une pétition qui
a recueilli près de 20 000 signatures
non à l'idéologie transgenre à l'école
changement de genre à l'école la
déléguée générale de SOS Éducation tire
la sonnette d'alarme elle s'explique ce
soir dans TPMP
juste on va on va lancer une question
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez chez vous
on vous allez vous demander plus il y a
moyen que j'aime bien quand il y a des
questions mais ils ont pas posé de
questions c'est normal merci Sophie au
duché d'être avec nous merci délégué
général SOS Éducation et merci à mon
quart de zéro d'être là très content
quand je te vois et tu lances un nouveau
média aussi à part le magazine qui est
formidable envers des affaires un
nouveau média sous la forme d'une
plateforme VOD ça s'appelle 15-0.tv
c'est un média dédié à la lutte contre
la pédocrinalité oui c'est-à-dire que
j'ai constaté que il y avait énormément
de documentaires qui ont été faits de
par le monde et que tu trouves pas même
sur Youtube pour des raisons
mystérieuses et j'ai décidé de racheter
ces documentaires de les traduire et de
diffuser et donc c'est une petite
plateforme tu me diras c'est une niche
mais en même temps je pense que ça
touche énormément de monde puisque je te
rappelle que 1/5 c'est une personne sur
5 qui dans sa vie a été abusé et donc
l'important de le faire ça fait partie
du travail aussi de faire ça et tu t'es
surtout posé la question pourquoi tu
arrivais pas à remettre la main sur sur
des documentaires absolument
extraordinaires
par exemple tu as tu as une bande aux
États-Unis autour d'un gars qui
s'appelle timbalarde et eux ils font
carrément c'est des anciens avis cils
c'est des c'est des mecs c'est des mecs
strong et on dirait un programme Netflix
sauf que c'est en vrai ils vont ils par
exemple ils arrivent en hélicoptère en
Colombie et il sauve des enfants mais ça
je devrais le voir sur Netflix et
apparaît ça y est pas d'accord quoi
parce que le sujet gêne c'est toujours
la même histoire c'est ce que tu nous
disais vendredi alors Sophie merci
d'être là et je voudrais vraiment avoir
la vie alors là des téléspectateurs et
des personnes autour de la table faut-il
s'inquiéter de cette affaire de plus en
plus d'enfants demandent à changer de
sexe qui souhaite changer d'identité de
plus en plus tôt c'est sa Sofia oui
c'est ça
à partir de quel âge quand vous dites de
plus en plus tôt en fait ce qui est
important de de considérer c'est qu'en
fait en France comme dans beaucoup
d'autres pays
du nord de l'Europe où de l'Occident en
général des pays plutôt riches on a
adopté un modèle qui s'appelle de
l'affirmation du genre ressenti
c'est-à-dire qu'on considère aujourd'hui
d'un point de vue de société qu'il n'y a
plus de réalité du sexe biologique donc
on ne reconnaît pas le sexe de naissance
de l'enfant et on considère que l'enfant
doit s'autodéterminer
quel que soit son âge mais surtout quel
que soit son histoire de vie quel que
soit son parcours personnel et ça sans
aucune limite d'âge donc ça peut être
trois ans à 4 ans à 5 ans à 10 ans à 15
ans etc et la question que ça pose
aujourd'hui c'est qu'en fait on est
passé à dans une période où on pouvait
être au milieu de lutte de classe à des
luttes de sexe et genre et cette lutte
de sexe de genre aujourd'hui c'est un
enjeu politique majeur pour lesquels la
plupart des experts et des scientifiques
ne sont pas d'accord et sur lequel il y
a pas de consensus et nous on considère
qu'il est dramatique aujourd'hui
d'installer cette idéologie dans les
corps alors dans l'école alors qu'on
sait bien que de nombreux pays font
marche arrière puisque c'est dangereux
pour la santé mentale et évidemment
physique des enfants très important et
le souci qui est c'est pour ça que
vraiment Cyril Hanouna merci de nous
donner la parole ce qui nous ce qui est
dramatique aujourd'hui c'est que la
parole sur ce débat n'est pas apaisée
elle est censurée c'est à dire vous ne
pouvez pas aujourd'hui questionner la
position d'un enfant qui voudrait
changer de genre sans être considéré
comme étant obligatoirement
transformable or le sujet n'est pas là
et on sait bien on a beaucoup de
personnes d'ailleurs transexuelles qui
prennent position pour protéger les
enfants et ça n'a rien à voir avec le
combat légitime évidemment pour la cause
des personnes homosexuelles ou des
personnes transexuelles ce n'est pas le
sujet la question c'est comment
aujourd'hui on voit exploser les courbes
c'est à dire que dans l'histoire il
pouvait arriver à un enfant né petit
garçon de se sentir petite fille et ça
arrivait très tôt c'est à dire
généralement c'est entre 18 mois et 4
ans et cet enfant il était
pris par une souffrance tellement
puissante que ses parents ne jouez pas
considérer qu'elle était pas réelle et à
ce moment là il était accompagné et tout
le travail des scientifiques des
médecins des pédopsychiatres allaient
être de savoir si cet enfant il a les
fréquentiler avec son sexe de naissance
au fil des années ou s'il deviendrait
une personne transexuelle mais le fait
de d'être une personne transexuelle ça
sous-entend des traitements
médicamentaux qui sont très lourds
réversibles déchirurgies invasives qui
sont très lourdes et réversibles et qu'à
se motif là faut pas se tromper et vous
dites vous dites donc pour vous à
l'école pour vous il faut plus aborder
ce sujet alors écoutez à l'école il ne
faut pas en tous les cas mettre dans la
tête des enfants que le sexe biologique
n'a pas de réalité métabolique puisqu'il
en a une c'est ce que disent noter les
spectateurs et qu'il ne faut pas leur
dire
que à partir du moment ils sont mal dans
leur basket parce qu'on a tous vécu ça
parce que obligatoirement de de sexe de
genre bien sûr je veux dire quand vous
êtes un garçon et que vous êtes une
fille vous dites mais qu'est-ce que
j'aimerais être un garçon et quand vous
êtes adolescent avec
l'hypersexualisation actuelle
l'obsession du paraître bah les jeunes
filles elles sont pas toutes comme Kim
Kardashian et à ce titre là elle se
disent mais si moi je suis pas kim
Kardashian est-ce que je suis vraiment
une fille et à ces questions là il faut
prendre le temps de la réflexion parce
que
ce sont des filles qui veulent changer
de sexe aujourd'hui à cause de Tik Tok
d'instagrammaire elle regarde j'ai pas
le niveau bah je vais être un garçon
finissant
physiques bien sûr je suis pas comme ça
donc je veux passer je donc c'est
n'importe quoi on est dans la famille
moi je m'occupe des enfants et donc je
me dis là aussi on touche aux enfants et
on touche aux enfants d'une façon
absolument folle et stupide bien sûr et
et il faut arrêter cette machine qui est
lancée c'est évidemment pas contre les
LGBT on a on a soutenu leur combat parce
que on a ce niveau il y a un instant
depuis même il y a eu des bonnes choses
de Mai 68 ça en fait partie et il faut
le reconnaître il faut bien leur
expliquer qu'on n'est pas contre eux du
tout on leur dit juste un truc pas les
enfants attendez qu'ils soient pubère
c'est très inquiétant parce que un
enfant d'abord ça c'est dû qu'on lui
apprend des choses et effectivement on
est en train de lui laisser entendre il
peut choisir sa sexualité comme un
vêtement une voiture c'est un jouet
d'accord exactement ça effectivement 80%
ce sont des filles aussi pour des
raisons de violence parce que le monde
est de plus en plus violent et que si on
a un homme on a plus de chance de s'en
sortir évidemment c'est très grave là où
je rejoins madame c'est que ce qui était
grave avant c'est que quand on souffrait
dans un corps ça prenait entre 5 à 7 ans
c'est ça pour changer il fallait voir
des psy des psy des psy et des psy ça a
été réduit donc effectivement tout le
travail des professeurs aujourd'hui des
psy CDD à faire en sorte qu'une personne
trouve sa sexualité mais en revanche
elle doit pas la choisir ou pire ne pas
en avoir petite anecdote mais qui m'a
fait sourire sans me faire sourire j'ai
été dans un grand magasin il y a pas
très longtemps et le enfin pour moi
enfin pardon mais je le monsieur se
retourne et je dis bonjour monsieur et
de manière un peu désagréable il me dit
qu'est-ce qui vous permet d'affirmer ça
bah tu as une barbe alors j'étais plus
vulgaire je lui dis tu as une [ __ ]
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire alors on dit
quoi
vestimentairement des choses qui lui
plaisent plus qu'un garçon va mettre des
jupes moi ça ne me gêne absolument pas
parce que c'est une définition on a dit
que les garçons mettaient des pantalons
et pourquoi après tout Gauthier mettez
bien des jupes etc
ou rien ne déterminé non mais est-ce que
vous dites est très important
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement on a une
génération précédente qui à qui on a
qu'on a éduqué parce que là il faut
savoir aussi comprendre l'éducation aux
parents c'est-à-dire qu'on on prend
l'éducation et l'autorité parentale des
parents pour instruire non pas les
enfants mais pour les éduquer de la
manière dont on considère qu'il faudrait
les éduquer c'est-à-dire dans la
déconstruction et notamment dans le
bouquinisme nous enfin la génération
précédente on a été élevé et on nous
disait tu as mille manières d'habiter
ton corps de femme ou 1000 manières
d'habiter ton corps d'homme alors il y
en a qui est pas d'accord avec vous
c'est Gilles Verdez en fait c'est une
vision rétrograde de la société
alors en fait madame le problème c'est
que
hélas pour vous tous les psychiatres
vous demande totalement à 4 5 6 ans
aujourd'hui tous les psychiatres
alors laissez-le finir parce que c'est
faux j'ai même pas fini ma phrase d'où
tu sors ces chiffres 100 % de toutes les
analyses que j'ai lu aujourd'hui pour
préparer pour 6 ans et une
conscientisation chez les enfants de
savoir s'ils veulent se sentir garçon ou
fille et je félicite l'éducation si tu
appuies à 6 ans parce qu'on va reprendre
l'exemple si tu as bien 6 ans tu avais
dit je veux devenir un garçon tu aurais
dit oui je l'aurais accompagné dans son
changement comme l'éducation nationale
sont pas capable de choisir à partir de
6 ans il y a une conscientisation
si elle souhaitait se sentir tu lui dis
pas attends un peu on va voir avec elle
et j'accompagne le processus et Cyril ce
que je voudrais vous dire c'est qu'à
partir de maintenant l'éducation
nationale française 14 heureusement ne
vous écoute pas puisque maintenant à
l'école il y a une prise de conscience
de ça vous le savez très bien et vous
comme si ce n'était pas le cas
maintenant
les enfants pourront utiliser les
enfants je fais semblant de pas savoir
les enfants
que vous donnez
si vous me dites que je dis que je ne
suis pas conscient de ce que vous dites
c'est que vous parlez à mon nom en
l'occurrence je suis très bien
consciente il s'avère que quand je
prends des positions sur des sujets je
peux vous assurer un truc si je les ai
plutôt pas mal étudié donc vous parlez
puisque vous êtes extrêmement rétrograde
éducation il y a 3 ans et demi et j'ai
changé un peu c'est dur non mais
attendez
l'avortement là
les enfants pourront maintenant utiliser
est-ce que vous savez ce qui se passe
hein qui va prendre des bloqueurs de
puberté avant qu'il a atteint la Pubert
terrifie cet enfant n'aura jamais jamais
la possibilité de savoir ce que c'est
que le désir c'est-à-dire que votre
enfant ne connaîtra jamais de sa vie le
désir sexuel et de relation intime avec
qui que ce soit alors moi je vais vous
dire une chose c'est que vous pouvez
donner des leçons aux parents mais moi
je vais dire aux parents qui nous
écoutent si vous avez votre enfant qui
vous dit je me ressens d'un autre sexe
ou d'un autre genre il faut l'écouter il
faut l'accompagner il faut l'emmener
chez un pédopsychiatre qui ne va pas lui
dire oui il y a pas de problème on va te
filer des bloqueurs de puberté et cet
endroit va l'accompagner on va essayer
de comprendre pourquoi il souffre et on
va vérifier si cette souffrance n'est
pas autre chose qu'une dysphorie de
genre c'est-à-dire une incongruence
entre le sexe biologique et le sexe
psychique et à se motif là peut-être
qu'on attendra que cet enfant soit formé
parce que sinon cet enfant
on va l'enfermer dans une émotion d'un
enfant de 6 ans je peux vous répondre
parce que d'abord le mien est contre il
ne sort pas comme ça des études comme ça
des fois
qui était parti là-dedans on renoncé
depuis voilà l'histoire de la clinique
tavistoque et 10000 enfants en
Angleterre sont passés dans les griffes
de cette clinique et aujourd'hui ils ont
tout arrêté et ils présentent à un
moment donné de ses gosses dont la vie a
été foutue en l'air donc ne dis pas de
conneries s'il te plaît alors Amel
qu'est-ce que tu penses de ce que dit
Gilles raconte n'importe quoi
mais ils sont complètement tarés c'est
un enfant à 6 ans il a pas de conscience
mais non il sait pas encore
là
vous écoutez à vous écouter pourquoi
l'éducation nationale a évolué c'est
parce qu'il y a des suicides c'est parce
qu'il y a des dépression il y a des
enfants qui sortent
[Musique]
l'éducation nationale vient de changer
maintenant et permettre à ses enfants
d'avoir un accès aux toilettes à la
douche d'avoir un changement de prénom
possible parce que leur comportement
prouve que les enfants
de dépression et de suicide quand ils
sont adultes transsexuels il y a eu des
Suisses parce que ce n'était pas une
étude documentaire endomisée qui prouve
une alimentation de suicide les enfants
sont dépressifs avant d'engager
inclusive pour que tout le monde s'y
retrouve quelque chose moi quand j'étais
jeune je voulais être garçon aussi comme
elle a dit Valéry jeunesse ma mère elle
m'a dit Véronique
j'ai mis un jogging et des baskets et ça
m'est passé comme a dit la dame voilà on
verra quand ils seront pas du tout
donc voilà donc
c'est une femme qui a décidé on peut pas
les laisser choisir à 6 ans c'est pas un
gamin qui choisit
comme si un enfant pouvait décider
n'importe quoi bien sûr de changer de
gens n'importe quoi qui n'a pas droit de
conduire de boire de fumer que c'est ça
détermination sexuelle
des hormones
avant la puberté la folie en marche sur
la route
beaucoup de choses mais on n'a pas parlé
de la pression aussi qui avait les
enfants avant d'aller la pression au
collège au lycée quand on grandissait
maintenant dès 6 ans on leur met dans
leur tête à eux les enfants en leur
mettant la pression en leur faisant tu
veux être un homme ou une possible
ce serait jamais posé là
on lui dit le vrai problème il est là
pour poser la question c'est qu'on doit
attendre la puberté comme vous le disiez
justement vous lisiez la puberté que il
y a déjà énormément de problèmes qui
seront réglés avant mais sur l'espace
alors ce que je dis à Gilles pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas 4 ans comme l'éducation
nationale dit que c'est normal vous
dites que c'est normal je dis
l'éducation nationale a dit que c'était
normal parce que tous les psychiatres et
tous les animaux
donc on est intervenu et on a permis aux
enfants qui dès l'âge de 6 ans ont une
conscience de ça avec leurs parents on
leur a permis d'aller vers un changement
et surtout et surtout magazine
[Rires]
je l'ai lu c'est très intéressant
vendredi
je comprends pas en fait tu peux pas
faire ça une enfant de 6 ans c'est
peut-être un fils oui ou un fils peu
importe il est adulte je veux bien après
l'adolescence mais à 6 ans on lui a mis
ça dans la tête et c'est pas l'école de
lui mettre ça dans la tête
énormément mais ce que tu dis est dingue
si on lui laisse pas ce choix le petit
il va pas se poser la question c'est
l'enfant qui va faire la démarche
accompagné
je veux attends je veux conduire une
voiture tu vas dire ouais bah c'est
pourquoi
non mais fondre la personne de l'enfant
comme un adulte en miniature il faut
quand même replacer la position de
l'adulte et de l'enfant c'est l'adulte
de protéger l'enfant c'est pas un enfant
entre tout à l'heure pendant la pub que
j'ai trouvé extrêmement alarmante et
intéressante aussi elle me dit que les
milieux par exemple
en fait les gens pour parce qu'ils
préfèrent avoir des tranchants c'est à
dire de transformer un garçon en fille
plutôt que d'avoir un homosexuel et ça
je parle pour ça elle me parle en Iran
où elle me dit dans les milieux
américains très catho ils préfèrent
inciter les enfants à changer de sexe
très jeune pour pas avoir un homosexuel
parce que pour eux c'est une catastrophe
sur la tête dans cette société Guillaume
mais en fait on vit dans une société
tellement obsédée par l'inclusivité on
crée des sujets là où il y en a pas
l'enfant c'est un moment c'est normal de
se poser des questions de se sentir mal
dans sa peau il faut pas prendre le
moindre signe pour un bouleversement
c'est normal de se poser des questions
changer de sexe c'est quelque chose de
lourd c'est quelque chose de définitif
on ne change pas de sexe comment on
change de t-shirt et moi
c'est pas ça c'est qu'à l'école on leur
met ça dans la tête mais déjà c'est très
important qu'est-ce qui se passe si
c'est une crise passagère qu'est-ce qui
se passe c'est un enfant qui gère je
suis une fille je veux venir regarder
il n'y a pas de retour en arrière
à l'école c'est fait pour apprendre pas
pour info c'est les élèves c'est ça je
suis d'accord Castaldi ce monde me
dégoûte parce qu'effectivement il y a
des sujets il faut avancer mais le il le
yell le jeu le genre t'es masculin
féminin c'est pas dramatique de faire où
est le problème après à 16 ans oui on
peut faire un choix mais là tu te rends
compte tu vas tu vas dire tu vas dire
oui une petite fille je veux devenir un
garçon et inversement sur quelle base
moi j'ai des enfants j'ai un enfant de 2
ans que je sais pas trop hein je sais
combien j'en ai mais voilà c'est si
demain mon fils se pose des questions je
m'interroge mais effectivement
l'accompagner pour aller voir un
pédopsychiatre mais mais en aucun cas je
vais aller je vais la compagnie pour
dire tu vas changer de sexe je veux être
une fille très bien mais on va essayer
le docteur je vais tout couper puis on
change mais ça va pas la tête c'est
n'importe quoi c'est n'importe quoi
avec l'histoire de la disparition de
Mademoiselle tu te rends compte que
l'éducation nationale de dire des
enfants qu'on disant bonjour madame
c'est n'importe quoi c'est n'importe
quoi quoi non heureusement mademoiselle
heureusement mademoiselle a disparu
mademoiselle parce que d'après la
majorité des psychiatres
il a raison
comme ça c'est pas possible il a raison
mademoiselle qui a disparu c'est
dramatique toi tu es content toi
mademoiselle est une honte c'est une
discrimination
[Applaudissements]
je vais dire pourquoi je vous signale
quand même que ça a disparu
[Applaudissements]
une typologie dira une femme
mademoiselle ça veut dire signaler qu'on
pense ou qu'elle n'est pas mariée donc
c'est la caractériser et on n'a pas
caractériser mademoiselle par contre tu
as le droit de dire connard
non c'est bon ça va Raymond qu'est-ce
que tu en penses cet après Mathieu tu
vas flatteur moi
on a eu ce sujet il y a deux mois ou
trois mois ici on a déjà eu ce sujet là
et moi j'avais dit c'est pas aux enfants
de décider comme on fait tout cela avec
plein de convictions et plein de plein
de on est content on a la niaque mais on
a aucun un enfant on n'est pas concerné
et il y a beaucoup de parents qui
m'avaient écrit pour me dire au moins 40
il y a beaucoup de parents qui m'avaient
écrit pour me dire on en est vraiment
nous dans une vraie souffrance moi ce
que je pense c'est que trois six ans je
pense que tu peux pas décider parce que
le chemin en sens inverse c'est
réversible donc je pense que 3 6 ans
c'est tôt mais je pense que 10 12 ans 14
ans
avec un encadrement peut-être avec un
encadrement psychologique à partir de 14
ans pourquoi pas écouter plus l'enfant à
partir de 14 ans 4 ans parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de parents il y a beaucoup de
gens comme la majorité si tu veux si tu
veux
Géraldine qu'on a pas entendu keno c'est
vrai qui est non alors qui est plutôt du
côté de Jean [ __ ] après le problème
c'est que Gilles il est un peu excessif
donc ah c'est Jules hein
donc en fait moi je suis d'accord avec
vous c'est-à-dire que si c'est à la mode
c'est non si c'est juste tendance c'est
non mais je pense quand même à beaucoup
d'enfants peut-être qui nous regardent
pas beaucoup mais quelques-uns ne
serait-ce que même un ou deux qui nous
regardent et qui ont vraiment une
dysphorie de gens l'héroïne du film
petite fille que vous avez sans doute vu
ou comme la petite Lili qui était venue
en fait la dysurie de genre c'est pas
juste pour se faire un tatouage ou un
persil ou pour être à la mode ou pour
être tendance c'est une vraie souffrance
et vous le savez et donc voilà je pense
qu'il faut quand même les accompagner il
faut les écouter on peut pas on peut pas
sous prétexte que voilà on est dans dans
une sorte de de fantasme walkie en
disant voilà il y a une sorte de
déferlante et de franchement à partir de
quel âge absolument pas après la puberté
jamais de la vie avec les enfants non
jamais avant la puberté pas avant la
puberté
c'est pas du tout il s'agit pas du tout
c'est vraiment une souffrance horrible
excuse-moi je t'adore Géraldine mais là
ton sujet on parle justement des gens
qui mettent ça dans la tête de de
personnes ils disent juste pour un jour
j'ai envie d'être un garçon parce que
j'ai envie de mettre un deux outils
sinon c'est pas le sujet
avec les mathématiques
alors je vais vous répondre pourquoi
madame est-ce qu'on donne des cours de
Disney oui on en parle dans des livres
oui on en parle les gens oui on met dans
les apprentissages
dans la tête des enfants sans limite
d'âge donc même six ans d'ailleurs vous
avez des petits livres pour enfants des
trois ans qui raconte l'histoire d'une
petite fille qui va reprendre la rentrée
scolaire de septembre en garçon et on
sait que ça va bien tu vas devenir
garçon
voilà je voudrais juste répondre à ça
insupportable il faut laisser les
enfants grandis Audrey juste proposer un
tout petit peu d'espace d'un soucien aux
enfants et une certainement pas les
mettre au coeur de guerre d'adultes vous
disiez monsieur que tous les psychiatres
sont d'accord c'est faux il y a un
combat de psychiatre de médecins sur
cette question ils ne sont pas d'accord
pour la simple et bonne raison c'est que
tous les pays du Nord qui ont 10 20 30
ans d'ancienneté sur l'accompagnement
reviennent sur leur position et qu'en
Suède et en Norvège aujourd'hui sauf
qu'à exceptionnel les bloqueurs de
puberté sont interdits et tous les
traitements sont interdits avant 18 ans
c'est pas par hasard si tout le monde
était d'accord pour dire c'était
formidable et que ça sauvé du des
enfants tout le monde le ferait parce
que personne veut la souffrance des
enfants ça paraît tellement évident ce
que vous dites vous avez raison je
connais de l'histoire de ce qu'on
appelle la dysphorie de genre et qui
devrait être renommée incongruence que
je vous expliquais tout à l'heure c'est
à dire le fait pour un enfant
profondément d'avoir une différence
entre ton sexe biologique et son sexe
psychique Google ça concerne 1 sur 10
000 garçons depuis 100 ans et 1 sur 20
000 fils c'est à dire deux fois moins de
filles aujourd'hui les statistiques
explosent c'est-à-dire que c'est x 1000
des taux qu'on avait avant et c'est 80%
de jeunes filles parmi ces jeunes filles
qui veulent devenir des garçons une
majorité d'entre elles ont des
antécédents de situations psychot
psychologique soit elles sont des jeunes
filles qui auraient dans les années 80
plutôt été vers de l'anorexie mentale
soit on a des états dépressifs donc il
faut les avoir on a des instincts
c'est quand vous n'avez pas d'alignement
entre le sexe biologique c'est-à-dire
que vous avez un sexe de femme et que
votre cerveau psychiquement est
convaincu qu'il était un homme 50 c'est
très comme c'est 18 mois 4 ans
ont traité l'inconcluence alors
effectivement à l'époque il a été traité
de manière avec des pratiques
psychopathologiques très dures notamment
la castration et aujourd'hui le le
l'attitude qu'on a c'est une attitude
presque de compensation parce qu'on a
honte de ce qu'on a fait dans ces années
là aujourd'hui le problème qui se pose
n'est pas de reconnaître que pour un
nombre infime d'enfants cette situation
de souffrance elle est réelle la
caractéristique de cette situation de
souffrance est que l'origine est dans
cette non alignement il n'est pas dans
un état dépressif et le problème qu'on
aujourd'hui les médecins c'est
d'accompagner ses enfants sur
suffisamment long pour pouvoir poser un
diagnostic véritable pourquoi parce que
si jamais on fait un faux diagnostic ces
enfants vont prendre des médicaments qui
devront prendre toute leur vie qui va
conditionner un risque sévère qui seront
infertiles et qui n'auront pas accès
et les chirurgiens qui se font un pognon
mammouths
pas les prix là c'est un cauchemar
c'est-à-dire que les mecs
ils passent sur le billard des 14 ans
c'est n'importe quoi
ça on te qui commence à pousser et ainsi
de suite et on te file et les évidemment
les hormones et donc il y a un pognon de
bref
il est dangereux et surtout tu dis des
bêtises alors quand tu dis des bêtises
sur l'Amour est dans le pré on s'en tape
mais quand c'est des surjets sur des
sujets importants quand tu dis 100% des
petits catch on considère déjà qu'il
faut à peu près 40 ans à peu près 40 ans
pour qu'une étude puisse être valable
par exemple aujourd'hui sur la GPA sur
tout ça sans savoir si deux papas de
maman ça donnera des enfants normaux pas
normaux on va attendre peut-être 20 ans
30 ans 40 ans pour voir s'il y a des
taux de suicide tout ça voilà déjà c'est
pas possible parce que tout ça est
nouveau deuxièmement c'est pas la place
de l'école effectivement
on l'a dit donc c'est c'est ridicule
pour les enfants sont harcelés à l'école
quel rapport donc c'est bien de savoir
exactement que tu te situes à toi et
encore une fois ne fait pas que
instruire l'école
c'est d'être éduqué et si un jour
justement tu l'éduces mal et parce que
c'est un caprice et qui te reproche là
en revanche tu pourras t'en vouloir toi
toute ta vie s'il est dans le mauvais
sexe alors un enfant ça s'accompagne ça
ne choisit pas moi je l'accompagne les
enfants à l'école non mais dans la vie
avec votre idéologie qui n'évolue pas en
fonction des morts
de Mathieu tu aimes pas beaucoup non
plus
vous êtes comme ça
à la famille de l'élève qui s'est
suicidé en décembre 2020 après avoir été
renvoyé parce qu'elle ne pouvait pas je
dis elle elle ne pouvait pas porter de
jupes
de porter un jugement sur une affaire
aussi dramatique et c'est ça
n'a rien à voir
[Applaudissements]
exactement un cas et j'en suis fier un
seul cas un être humain un enfant une
enfant et vous vous généralisez non je
me suis dit
c'est un suicide mais non j'ai pas
changé d'avis poker
avant avant une transformation physique
une opération et un et des médicaments
je veux dire on peut un enfant il très
jeune en plus si vous lui mettez une
jupe et vous laissez pousser les cheveux
il aura l'air d'une petite fille donc
rien n'empêche si jamais vous les
enfants ont envie de se sentir mieux
dans quelque chose pourquoi aller
jusqu'à l'opération pourquoi elle est
les obliger
pourra aller pourquoi aller vers je veux
dire on peut l'accompagner différemment
pourquoi ne pas attendre que la puberté
pour aller vers quelque chose de plus
parce qu'avant les évolutions que je
souhaite et que porte heureusement
il y a eu des Suisses de jambes
il y a eu des suicides des dépression
alors ça c'est la distance entre vous et
mes enfants
pas tous en même temps qu'est-ce que tu
as contre Sophie là oui non mais
franchement
apaiser des éléments factuels
qui peut vous séduire Cyril et j'en suis
fort mari euh parce que vous êtes très
intelligent ton mari elle masque elle
masque sous ce discours une idéologie
une idéologie extrêmement rétrograde en
association
[Applaudissements]
excuse-moi
mais je croyais dans notre pays elle est
pas de délit d'opinion elle a le droit
aussi
mais moi je suis pour l'avortement mais
elle a le droit d'être contre on peut
vouloir absolument
ils font
un mauvais process est-ce que vous
croyez que
Sophie dans l'envers des affaires
qui est confié ma pauvre bien sûr
frigide Barjot de la manif pour tous
vous souvenez de la lettre que je lui
envoyais vous savez que je ne suis pas
je passe soupçonnable d'être un mec de
droite non non j'ai fait le vrai journal
pendant suffisamment de temps pour que
vous eniez compte mais sur un sujet
aussi grave qu'elle soit pour ou contre
la porte l'appartement l'avortement
l'appartement c'est Simone Plaza il est
contre la contribution
et peu importe ah non là où je rejoins
mais c'est son c'est pas ou quoi
sur ce problème des enfants qu'on emmène
vers un choix beaucoup trop tôt je me
retrouve parfaitement dans ce qu'elle
dit après elle a le droit d'être